PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Build with Google Cloud
where we build
reference architectures.
In this video, we will
build an e-commerce platform
on Google Cloud.
What are your options?
Stay with me to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's say you're a retailer
that sells pet products, shoes,
cars, anything.
Did you know that
digital commerce platform
can be built and modernized
in multiple ways?
I am Priyanka
Vergadia, developer
advocate here at Google Cloud.
And today, let's see
what your options
are to build a digital
e-commerce platform on Google
Cloud.
You ready?
Let's go.
[MOTOR SPINNING]
First, you can build your
own e-commerce platform
on Google Cloud.
Why does this make sense?
Because it provides the agility
to create new capabilities
using data insights and access
to machine learning and AI
tools within Google Cloud.
There are two ways to
build your own platform.
You could either migrate your
existing e-commerce platform
or modernize using containers.
Migrate means lifting and
shifting your current platform
as-is into the Cloud.
This is the lowest risk and
fastest way to get to Cloud.
It is suitable for custom
built e-commerce stack
leveraging heavy OSS
or running on premises.
And once you've migrated,
you are on your path
to modernization.
You could choose to
migrate and improve
where you can upgrade
and improve or optimize
using containerised approach.
This means you're willing
to move to containers
and are gradually moving
to Google Cloud managed
services, such as GKE.
It sets the stage for a more
seamless modernization path
to microservices on GKE.
If the goal is to modernize
your commerce application
platform completely for benefits
of Cloud and speed to market,
then you would re-architect
to adopt containers using
microservices architecture.
This helps you shift
focus to creating
those differentiated customer
experiences for digital
and omnichannel revenue growth.
We'll come back to architect,
the commerce migration
and modernization,
but before we do that,
let's also check out
the other options.
The second option is, you can
create a headless commerce
platform on Google Cloud.
This is where you actually
decouple the front end,
the mobile app, the CMS, et
cetera, from your back end
or your commerce layer.
This approach
provides flexibility
to your marketing
teams to quickly alter
front-end elements to run
campaigns, promotions,
and create most advanced
customer experience
on your front end.
You're building front-end
experience on Google Cloud
and are integrating
with commerce
back ends from Google Cloud
marketplace offering partners.
This unique approach offers
the benefits of the agility
to launch or change highly
personalized experiences,
flexibility to upgrade,
update, or replace
your dependent
systems, and scale
different parts of solutions
independent of each other.
As you can imagine,
this approach
has a low total cost of
ownership, smaller IT teams,
and is not constrained
by a monolithic roadmap
and timelines to offer
new storefront features.
Third option?
You could use out-of-the-box
SaaS solution on Google Cloud
marketplace, such as Shopify,
BigCommerce, or HCL Commerce.
This will work for you if you
require minimum customizations
and can take advantage of
Google Cloud for customer 360
and data insights-driven
analytics.
Which of these
approaches are you
leaning towards to build your
e-commerce platform, and why?
Share in the comments.
Let's dive into the
first two approaches--
build your own and headless
commerce-- one by one
to understand what
it takes to build
and which one makes
sense for your use case.
Now let's architect
the build your own,
migrate, and improve approach.
This means you're not
just migrating but also
looking to break down a
legacy monolith commerce
application into a set of
microservices that can help you
gain agility in launching
those new features in a way
to improve customer
experience by leveraging
data insights that are powered
by AI and ML capabilities.
In order to do
this, you're going
to need to migrate and
improve using containerization
on Google Kubernetes Engine.
Let's see how.
You would deploy your
application servers
and your database as services
and containers inside a GKE
cluster.
You can accelerate this
process of moving to GKE
by using Migrate for Anthos,
Google's migration automation
tool.
All your static content--
including the
images, media assets,
web files-- will be
stored in Cloud Storage.
Any other application systems
that still exist on premises
will be hooked up via a
dedicated interconnect Cloud
VPN or API management.
Now let's see the request flow.
The user makes a request
from their phone,
website, or chat
application, which
then gets resolved by cloud DNS
to a global any past IP address
for Cloud Load Balancing.
Cloud Armor works
alongside Load Balancing
to provide DDoS protection
and web application
firewall that detects and
blocks layer 7 attacks.
reCAPTCHA Enterprise
provides bot protection.
And API defense provides
protection for abuse of APIs.
Combination of Cloud
Armor, Apigee API defense,
and reCAPTCHA Enterprise
offer the web application
and API Protection.
Once the request is
validated by these,
it is then sent
to the web server.
The web server then grabs
the static content--
such as your images,
CSS, your JavaScript--
to render that page
from Cloud Storage.
It also stores them in Cloud CBN
for next request, which helps
with performance and latency.
Next, web server
would need to interact
with the app server for
business logic, such as,
is this item in-store?
The internal load balancing
between the web and application
servers help
distribute the load.
Once the request lands
on the app server,
it interacts with the
database to get the response.
Yes, the item is in-store,
and there are four more
left, or something like that.
Gets this information
and then sends it back
to the user via web servers.
Now, if the request
requires the app server
to gather information from a
service that is on-premises,
then it can make a call
to the service via an API
through Apigee
API gateway or VPN
over the internet or
just direct connectivity
to that data center.
If the request was a surge
or recommendations, then
app server interfaces with
the Google retail search
or the recommendations API to
present the appropriate results
to the user.
Architecturally, build your
own, migrate, and improve
provides you the flexibility
to add features, ability
to scale easily by adding more
GKE clusters during traffic
spikes.
It also offers
applications the security
using a combination of
Cloud Armor, Load Balancer,
reCAPTCHA, and API defense.
From the business perspective,
the build your own
and migrate and improve
approach enables the integration
with the data
platform which creates
a strong closed loop between the
data platform and the commerce
platform.
You can collect the
first party customer data
from shopper interactions on
their modern digital commerce
platform to use in
your data platform
for predictive analytics
and marketing activation.
You can also gain insights
from data in data platform
to offer personalized shopping
experiences and promotions
on the digital commerce site.
Are you ready to
migrate and improve?
We've got a link to
the documentation below
to help you out.
Now, how would you architect
your migration as-is
or lift and shift your
e-commerce platform
to Google Cloud?
Say your priority is
to move to Google Cloud
as quickly as possible or
you have a homegrown OSS
stack based on-premises,
an e-commerce platform that
is unique and works well and
you just want to migrate.
That means you just
want to migrate as-is
without making any changes.
Just get to the Cloud so
you can take that first step
towards modernization.
For an as-is
migration like this,
we recommend migrating
to Compute Engine
virtual machines.
Let's see how to architect this.
Your request flow pretty
much stays the same,
except for your
web and application
servers and your database.
You will create your web
and application servers
on Compute Engine managed
instance groups, which
will scale based on the number
of requests you receive.
You will also deploy your
primary and secondary databases
on Compute Engine instances.
This architecture
offers the ability
to scale the web and app tiers
independently using the managed
instance groups and provides
low-latency responses back
to the end customer to keep
them engaged in their buying
journey.
You have the same
application security
using a combination of
Cloud Armor, Load Balancer,
reCAPTCHA, and API Defense.
In addition, it allows
you as a retailer
to quickly meet unexpected user
traffic spikes without having
a large-sized
deployment initially,
but automatically scale
easily up and down enabled
by your configuration policies.
Are you ready to migrate your
e-commerce application as-is?
We've got a link in the
documentation to help you out.
Now, let's say you have
migrated to Google Cloud using
GKE or Compute Engine,
or you're building
an entire modernized e-commerce
platform from scratch.
How would you go from here to
modernized, fully-containerized
microservices architecture?
Let's see.
All your requests flow stays
the same as you saw earlier.
What changes is that
now you're going
to think about smaller
services and separate them out
into four layers--
presentation layer, which could
be your single-page application
builder and content; a services
layer, which would include
services, such as sessions,
search, account, inventory,
orders, and anything
else that you can think
of; the storage layer,
which would be your storage
choices for those services.
There could be
different storages
based on the kind of service--
for example, Cloud SQL or
Spanner for inventory products
and maybe Firestore
for sessions.
Cache layer would be
your transient cache
using memory store to
access recently queried data
without querying the
storage layer again.
You can now see the flexibility
that this architecture allows
you to have.
You can add and deploy
any new services any time
without affecting
any other services.
You can also have
different teams
working on different services
in different programming
languages.
Lots more flexibility both
from the development side
and from the
business side, which
leads to happy developers
and happy customers.
And you have enabled
your business
to have a strong closed
loop between the data
platform and the
commerce platform
to understand customer
behavior and offer personalized
experiences.
Another huge advantage
of this approach
is the seamless integration with
other Google Cloud Services,
such as Workspace, Maps,
G Pay, mobile, Android,
Chrome devices, and more.
Are you ready to start your
e-commerce modernization
journey?
We've got a link to a sample
code repository for you
to get started.
Now, let's take a deep dive into
the headless commerce solution.
As a retailer, you might
want to own and control
the front end for providing
an engaging and differentiated
shopping experience and leverage
the ready-to-use back-end
commerce building
blocks for capabilities,
such as product catalog,
pricing, promotions, cards,
shipping, accounts,
and other things.
In this fast-paced world
where user behavior changes
every day, headless
commerce approach
is increasingly preferred
for speed-to-market.
You can easily launch new
experiences quickly and benefit
from innovations in
back-end capabilities
added by our partners on
Google Cloud Marketplace,
such as Commerce Tools.
How would you architect this?
Well, let's see.
The user would have the
same secured experience
using web application and
API security solution.
The front end is deployed
on GKE or Cloud Run
and can use Cloud Storage
for static assets,
and Firestore or Cloud SQL
for your dynamic storage
and database options.
Interacting with the
recommendations API
and retail search for an
engaging product discovery
and shopping experience, that
would reduce search abandonment
and increase sales conversions.
Commerce tools platform
from Marketplace
serves as the back end
for commerce operations.
It provides over 300 APIs for
e-commerce back-end needs,
such as your products,
categories, orders,
and other such things.
This approach is an alternative
to build or buy approach
as it offers a right
mix of both approaches
to realize a solution that
enables brand differentiation,
flexibility, and agility.
To help you get started
with headless commerce,
we've built an end-to-end demo.
Check it out below and
let us know how it goes.
We just looked at
the different options
to build a modern e-commerce
platform on Google Cloud.
Depending on your
situation, you can
choose to migrate as-is
to Compute Engine VMs,
migrate and improve
using containers,
build an entirely modern
microservices-based
architecture creating
containerized services,
or use partners offered services
to adopt headless commerce
approach.
Any direction you take is
a success and a great start
to gain agility in
launching new features,
innovation, and improving
customer experience
by leveraging data insights
powered by AI and ML,
and tools, such as retail
search and recommendations AI.
Now, it's your turn.
Go build the headless
commerce demo
with the documentation
and a full sample
code repository linked below.
If you like this
video, then I hope
you completely destroy those
like and subscribe buttons
to let us know.
I cannot wait to build
more stuff with you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]